[Music]
in today's eight on your side summertime
fun and summertime toys for your kids
ttpm.com stands for toys tots pets and
more and it tests thousands of toys
internally and
through reviews it has come up with its
best toys for this summer which include
the new hot wheels city toxic snake
strike from mattel
it's got slime involved the turtle
totter balance beam from kidkraft is
pretty cool the fisher-price laugh and
learn
so big puppy helps your kids and the new
nerf rival curve from hasbro
for some great outdoor play we have the
nerf rival curve from hasbro
it has a really cool design and what's
also new it's called curve because you
can adjust the nozzle
and then aim the ammo to go left right
up or down so just add some extra
strategy to your outdoor blaster bottles
this one is for ages 14 and up so it's
for older kids and adults
and we do also recommend that safety
goggles are worn when you're playing
with this blaster
ttpm also posts a lot of fun videos of
all
its fun toys on tick tock